welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Zack Snyder's Rebel Moon
part one a child of fire this is gonna
be a multi-part space epic first part
coming to Netflix December 22nd Zack
Snyder has said Rebel moon is influenced
by Seven Samurai Star Wars and 1981's
adult animated sci-fi film heavy metal
so there is a lot going on here let's
break down this trailer for all the
details he might have missed and why you
should be really pumped for this movie
let's get started
okay the trailer opens on the Netflix
logo of course which changes from this
burnished bronze color like the color of
A Warrior's helmet to its usual red a
hand brushes over wheat in a field in a
move reminiscent of gladiator but this
hand belongs to Jimmy a robot also known
as JC 1435 voiced by Anthony Hopkins and
played physically by Dustin Scythe
Hammer Jimmy was created centuries ago
to defend the king of the Galactic
Empire but has since been repurposed by
the evil Imperium and brought to the
peaceful farming satellite Moon of belt
this movie centers around the fact that
the Imperium which is the army of the
corrupt government the mother World
shows up on Belt demanding Harvest from
the locals and the locals hire a ragdag
group of Warriors to fight back hence
the Seven Samurai inspiration and yes if
it sounds like Pixar's A Bug's Life
Pixar is A Bug's Life is also a sudden
Samurai we cut to a shot of Jimmy
looking very hella for marvel-like in
this helmet with horns on it okay on to
the next clip do you know the story of
the princess Issa
[Music]
myth she was called the Dima okay we see
a young Cora here played by Elizabeth
Martinez followed by a bunch of ships
surrounding the planet if you think this
is the rebel moon it's not we're not
even going to see the titular Rebel moon
in this movie but more on that after the
next section it was said this child
would stop the madness of war that she
was to usher in a new age of peace and
compassion I was given memories of a
world I will never see okay General
Titus played by jaiman hansu is on his
knees looking out at the aftermath of a
battle fun fact Anthony Hopkins actually
played Titus andronicus in 1999's Titus
obviously based on the Shakespeare play
which dealt with andronicus's violent
deeds and downfall after coming home for
battle we cut to a group of men kneeling
with hoods over their heads that have an
eye with a teardrop design on them looks
like there's some interesting
mythological iconography that will be
explored in this new story verse the
Imperium are showing their power as the
ship blows up a huge statue shattering
the piece that Jimmy was just talking
about okay next clip
loyalty to a King I cannot serve
and love for a child
I could not save okay two people dressed
in all black stand at a funeral with a
big white griffin behind them a dead
King dressed in all white and clutch in
the scepter is carried by Paul bearers
and we cut two Nemesis played by Bay
doona holding a dead Child by a burning
Village we get some sort of Spaceport
with these people standing there
including this row of individuals on the
lower left who hold these lights this
could be the scribes a group of masked
priests from the mother world who can
implant memories into people and rewrite
history that way alright next slip
what do you think they want
found a scar Giver
I am a child of War alright we see adult
Korra played by Sophia boutella
frantically hitting the bell with a
hammer now if you watch Star Wars and or
this is something I did get messages or
Warnings out to the townsfolks so Cora
is likely one of the people of belt that
mother World ships are coming we get
this exchange what do you think they
want
everything and I'm sorry to be so
grounded in the MCU but this does remind
me of Thanos when he's in the soul realm
talking to Young Gamora and she asks
what it cost you and he goes everything
okay we see Admiral Atticus Noble leader
of the Imperium Army he's played by Ed
screen who was the original Dario
Naharis in Game of Thrones he was
actually replaced in that role by
Mikhail Houseman who also shows up in
Rebel Moon playing the character Gunner
Noble says that he found her the scar
giver and we get these awesome scenes of
Court kicking ass in what looks like a
pub we also see young core again in the
middle of a burning City ravaged by War
as a mother World tank fires a missile
okay next clip
I was taught that love is weakness
between Justice and revenge
we see more of Cory's past serving in
the Imperium she kisses a fellow soldier
who later dies in the snowy battle it's
clear that she was a top Soldier as she
stands on a battle beaten building
planted a flag that's blowing in the
wind and I don't know if it's just the
color scheme or the dramatic imagery but
I'm getting some Starship Troopers Vibes
here by Starship Troopers I mean fascist
then we meet the harmata an Alien Spider
Warrior played by Snyder Mainstay Jenna
Malone the character is very reminiscent
of the stalk from The Saga comic series
she looks like she's holding a child as
she talks to Nemesis who then busts out
these two red what could only be
described as laser swords let's call
them laser swords and we should point
out here that Zack Snyder originally
intended Rebel moon to be a Star Wars
movie he pitched this project during the
Disney acquisition of lucasfilm in 2012
but the project was scrapped this is all
while Snyder was in post-production for
Man of Steel Snyder never intended to
use any of the known characters from the
Star Wars franchise he wanted to tell a
story set in the Star Wars Universe off
to the side of the main plot lines we
all know but with more of an adult tone
to it that explains why this film has a
lot of star throughout it and this not
quite lightsaber but laser sword is one
of them do you need energy do you need
it now that's a job for one shot
one shot Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
everybody really one shot makes energy
choose and focus shoes so that you can
choose if you want to rev up or Zone in
each energy chew has 75 milligrams of
pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional neurotropics that give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew the Focus Shoes
come in new rockstars themed packaging
we use them all the time to get a
natural boost of focus and energy with B
C D and E vitamins plus zinc to help
with immune system support and the amino
acid tyrosine both energy to choose and
focus shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off your order alright
next clip
[Applause]
okay we cut to a cloaked Kai drawing a
gun Kai is part of the resistance team
and is played by sons of anarchies
Charlie Hunnam next we get a character
in a cape landing on the ground in that
classic Zack Snyder superhero Landing
pose then there's this figure in the
foreground who looks like he's wearing a
pork pie hat like Heisenberg Breaking
Bad so maybe the explosions down below
were caused by a meth lab blowing up
next part
one moment I did of this part
but I don't want no trouble
we're not here to bring any okay Noble's
boss Regent balisarius played by frothy
you remember him qazi from Hawkeye maybe
you don't because they really effed up
that character he stands it from this
large circular window he's just his
people asking for a moment before the
crown is placed on his head and he
proclaims that he does love this part
and yeah this totally reminds me of
Joaquin Phoenix as Commodus from
Gladiator this guy is a piece of [__]
then we get ray Porter acclaimed voice
actor who voiced Darkseid and Snyder's
Justice League saying I don't want no
trouble followed by ships blown up and
Cora with Kai saying we're not here to
bring any you can see a black Griffin in
the background unfurling its wings a
nice contrast with the white one we saw
earlier next clip are you ready
okay there's more of Nemesis with her
dual blades and then Tarak estas Nair
Another Game of Thrones actor asking are
you ready before the camera cuts to this
forearm Beast being cheered on in a
Coliseum we see Cora bathed in red light
before cutting to a group of people with
what looks like proton packs on their
back but are probably some sort of
farming equipment as an explosion causes
them to Duck and Cover then the hero
shot of resistance fighter dairy in
blood ax played by Ray Fisher next clip
all right we get another look up at that
black griffin from earlier rearing up on
tying legs as Tarik kneels in front of
it and what looks like an act of
deference and respect very Harry Potter
with the hippogriff if you ask me Tarak
then pets its head we see him doing a
slow motion jump onto its back from a
cliff and a move that looks like it's
straight out of 300. in fact one of the
writers on this film Kurt johnstead
wrote 300 in its sequel 300 rides of an
Empire then we cut to this awesome
looking alien who kind of resembles a
catfish just incredible effects and
design in this movie it has this symbol
on its forehead that might denote
belonging to some sort of religious or
mystical order again folks this is all
new IP it's not based on anything I
can't tell you what this stuff is we are
diving in an entirely new universe with
iconography and symbols that we're going
to be figuring out as we go all right
next clip the king is a man and a man
can fail
the myth is indestructible so Cora in
her mother World military uniform kneels
and some sort of church with stained
glass window depicting what looks like a
griffin there are two men in the room
with her one standing one sitting on a
throne with his head in his hands
looking defeated a crown cladded to the
ground just as Anthony Hopkins says man
can follow then there's a young girl in
the snow dressed in all white holding a
bird this looks like princess Isa who
was mentioned earlier played by Stella
Grace Fitzgerald in this whole scene
giving us some Narnia Vibes the bird
flies away and it transitions to Korra
looking up at the sky and reaching for
the Griffin flying overhead alright on
to the last clip
town has come for all that you love to
protect each other we show them your
mercy
[Music]
who among you
all right there's a group of mother
world soldiers engaged in battle looking
decidedly stormtroopery Titus gives a
rousing speech over scenes of Happiness
reminding people why they are fighting
there's an explosion in the Coliseum and
a Spaceport battle and then Cora and
Noble fight with these blue energy
blades and the final shot is of Korra
and the rebels walking toward the
Coliseum which is taken directly from
concept art that Snyder had previously
shared and we got to the rebel Moon
title card part one coming December 22nd
2023 and then part two coming April 19th
2024. they filmed part two immediately
after filming part one both of these
films will also get an extended R-rated
release at some point and yeah this
movie does look like something we need
to see on a big screen now back in April
Debbie Snyder producer and Zack Snyder's
wife confirmed that a part three is on
the way too in part three we will
finally see the actual Rebel Moon Zack
Snyder told Empire there's a planet
named bana and Vanna is the rebel moon
it's not even in one shot of this movie
and if you want even more of the Rainbow
Moon Cinematic Universe Schneider has
teased that a TV show could be in the
works that dives into bellisarius's
backstory as well as a video game he
told the Nerd Girls podcast that he was
in talks to develop an RPG for this IP
Snyder even has a 450 page Rebel Moon
Bible that goes into the history in the
lore of the mother World let me know in
the comments below what your what you're
excited for about this movie it might be
the coolest thing to come out in
December of this year please subscribe
to all three of our channels in the new
rockstars Network the main new rockstars
channel the break room and the Deep dive
you can support us by grabbing some
merch at nerdright.shop like this Ahsoka
inspired shirt follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you